wir schauen nun auf das eu parlament in
straßburg dort standen heute das thema
exit und der kampf gegen den plastikmüll
plastikmüll auf der tagesordnung auch
ein wichtiges thema zweifelsohne alles
wichtige themen über die da debattiert
wird
uns wurde aber berichtet einem ganz
anderen punkt ging es so richtig hoch
her
mein kollege klaus weber hat die debatte
dort in straßburg verfolgt herr weber
was war denn da los
es gebe in der tat eine denkwürdige
debatte heute hier im parlament
eigentlich sollten die gipfel ergebnisse
der vergangenen woche besprochen werden
auch über den dreck sieht sollte
gesprochen werden aber einigen waren die
ergebnisse von der letzten woche wohl
nicht spannend genug und so wendete sich
das blatt ganz schnell und plötzlich war
man mittendrin in einer debatte über
ideologie und geschichts auslegung
auslöser des ganzen war eine aussage vom
fraktionsvorsitzenden der europäischen
konservativen und reformer said kanal
der die sozialdemokraten angriff und was
danach folgte die reaktion und auch die
emotionen die darauf folgten die zeigen
doch einiges über den zustand der
europäischen union aktuell hier die
ausschnitte wird gesprochen von
rechtsextremismus
dann möchte ich daran erinnern dass die
nazis der nationalsozialismus ein
sozialismus ist eine linksgerichtete
ideologie die wollen das gleiche wie
sieht ja herr präsident um erstmal das
zu sagen das ist doch wohl die tatsache
ja sie hören das nicht gerne das ist mir
schon klar es heißt sozialismus
nationalsozialismus
viel ist passiert ich sage es ist eine
linksgerichtete ideologie erzählen sie
mir nichts anderes
ich glaube nicht dass es hier in diesem
saal altnazis gibt leute die sich
vielleicht auch mit freuden an die
sowjet diktatur erinnern das waren
beides schreckliche politische systeme
die den menschen und die ganz europa
schweren schaden zugefügt haben
gott sei dank sind diese beiden
diktaturen verschwunden dank der
europäischen union aber gibt es nichts
zu lachen
dort jetzt wirklich nichts zu lachen man
muss die position der anderen
respektieren
visus ab 100 in orange kultur lernen sie
dass die die anderen zu respektieren
wenn sie selbst was berg erzeugen wollen
herr fahrrad das ist demokratie eine
sehnsucht nach diktatur wenn man die
meinung der anderen nicht jetzt
eingestellt möchte ich hielt es nicht
für weise was sie ihre den getan haben
und halte es sogar für geboten dass es
sich entschuldigen denn über die nazis
als nationalsozialisten zu sprechen und
sie auf diese weise mit den sitzen mit
der sozialdemokratin fraktion in
verbindung zu bringen ist eine
beleidigung eine beleidigung für alle
sozialdemokraten gegen die nazis
gekämpft haben die ihr leben in
konzentrationslagern gegeben haben
ich hielte es für das beste wenn sie
sich entschuldigen
es gibt hunderttausende von
sozialdemokratinnen und sozialdemokraten
von aufrechten demokraten von
anständigen menschen dem naziterror zum
opfer gefallen sind weil sie aufrechten
gang gepflegt haben weil sie die
demokratie und die menschenwürde
verteidigt haben
ich halte das für eine solche unsägliche
unverschämtheit von herrn kann man eine
solche entgleisung dieses parlamentes in
europa unwürdig dass ich sie herr
präsident auffordern möchte herrn kanal
zu bitten sich unmittelbar zu
entschuldigen
ich habe das langsam sagt dass die leute
immer sagen nationalsozialismus eine
rechtsgerichtete ideologie da sind wir
uns inhaltlich wohl nicht einig ich
glaube an die redefreiheit wenn ich sie
da beleidigt habe dann entschuldige ich
mich dafür wenn ich beleidige dann habe
ich sie vielleicht beleidigt dann
entschuldige ich mich dafür ohne
vorbehalte ich will nicht den
politischen gegner oder meine freunde
beleidigen dann entschuldige ich mich
das geordnete kammer hat sich
entschuldigt und er hat in seinem
beitrag wiederholt dass seines erachtens
die nationalsozialisten eine totalitäre
ideologie keine rechts ideologie
zu verstehen weder herr kemal noch sie
dass das für eine politische schweinerei
ist die sozialdemokraten in europa in
die nähe der faschisten zu rücken
ich bestehe auf einer erklärung es geht
nicht um meine persönliche unsere
persönliche befindlichkeit es ist ein
historischer irrsinn eine demo demagogie
der rechten in diesem haus zieht
maskieren ihre unfähigkeit politische
prozesse geschichtlich und aktuell zu
begreifen jetzt weiß ich genau des
geistes kind sie sind und herr präsident
sie sollten sich bitte nicht damit
identifizieren weil sie tun der farbe zu
der sie gehören keine er an der kammer
ich würde ihnen wirklich sehr empfehlen
schauen sie sich lesen sie klemperers
tagebücher lesen sie seine abhandlung
über die sprache des dritten reiches lte
linguatec imperia und sie werden
feststellen dass das was dort passiert
nämlich begriffe zu missbrauchen
umzudeuten
dass das nicht nur eine frage der
vergangenheit ist und der offensichtlich
mangelhaften auseinandersetzung
ihrerseits mit der geschichte europas
weshalb eigentlich die europäische union
ja nach den verheerenden krieg des
letzten jahrhunderts entstanden ist
sondern dass es heute aktuell ist um
meine sozialdemokratischen kollegen so
reagieren zurecht reagieren hat was
damit zu tun dass die begrifflichkeit
nationalsozialistisch national ob wieder
zusammengeführt wird dass es das wieder
gibt es gibt es in unseren ländern
erstehen menschen auf der straße die
waffen sammeln die ausländer überfallen
die linke überfallen
die morden in europa in unserer eu und
das müssten sie doch nur langsam hat
begriffen haben so sehr kann sich doch
nicht abgeschottet haben auf ihrer insel
von der geschichte europas sie gehören
noch dazu erscheinen und vormittag
schwierigkeiten mit unserem
geschichtsverständnis zu haben
zu behaupten dass die europäische union
hat jani den nationalsozialismus und der
sowjetischen kommunismus gestürzt habe
ist nicht nur lachhaft es ist ehrlich
gesagt unschön und eine beleidigung der
vereinigten staaten von amerika
die riesige enorme opfer gebracht haben
uns zu dem zu machen was es im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert wurde
und davon abgesehen auch das vereinigte
königreich wie 30.000 tote soldaten in
italien überzeugen
also sie können behaupten was sie wollen
aber die geschichte umschreiben können
sie nicht